all right what is the point of analyzing
music and what does that mean anyway now
when we're first learning a piece we're
probably most concerned about learning
the actual notes given to us by the
composer most likely in the form of a
score and we're given instructions about
what pitches to play when to play them
the dynamics tempo all of that so why
bother and take extra steps to analyze
the score further and how do we even go
about doing that for me analyzing a
piece of music has a lot to do with
gaining clarity and insight into the
music beyond certain impressions i have
of it while practicing it or listening
to it either through a recording or
someone else's performance
also there are so many different ways in
which we can analyze a piece so let's
actually start by talking about those we
can first start off by identifying the
genre or form say for example you're
learning a chopin mazurka this is opus
59 number one one of my favorite
mazurkas
[Music]
knowing that it's a berserker we can
take note of a few things first of all
it's in triple meter we know that it's a
dance form coming from the polish
tradition that it has a certain tempo
and lilting quality and a lot of times
there's an emphasis on the second and
third beats
knowing all of these can influence the
way that you carry on with the piece
with phrasing
pacing and tempo of course when we look
at the score we have all kinds of
markings there for us including phrase
marks those lines above the notes that
tell us how the melodies and phrases are
organized but if we further look at the
direction of these lines we can gather
some more clues in terms of the
inflection of these lines here we can
observe how there are phrases in
dialogue with each other first we have
one going downwards
[Music]
then upwards
[Music]
which is sort of like a reply and then
we have another one going downwards but
starting from a higher pitch
and then a reply upwards as well
and that one is elongated with a trill
[Music]
followed by an afterthought
maybe you're like me and you want to
know more about how a certain melody or
phrase was constructed and how it sits
on top of the underlying harmony knowing
that chopin's harmonic language is tonal
and more traditional we can identify the
key of the piece by looking at the key
signature and bookends of the piece
with that we can know the piece is in a
minor and we can analyze this opening
melody here in relation to the
underlying chords first outlining the a
minor chord
which is our minor one chord
followed by a v chord
e major
and then back to a minor
[Music]
now that we're familiar with the opening
section it can serve as a crucial
starting point for us literally for
analyzing the rest of the piece for form
and structure a lot of this type of
analysis involves paying attention to
where melodies or sections are repeated
transformed or abandoned and in this way
we can organize the piece as a whole in
larger chunks now there are a lot of
ways to do this and a lot of
pre-existing forms and labels to work
with for example letters
aba is ternary form you can pay
attention to maybe the sonata allegra
form which has intro exposition
development recapitulation coda that
sort of thing so there are a lot of
different ways of organizing these
sections with form in the realm of
harmony and music theory in general
there are a bunch of technical terms
being used which honestly can get quite
overwhelming augmented six chord
enclosure
accented non-chord tones
sequence
passing tones
but at the same time they come in handy
because in general not always but in
general they serve as a universal
language or coding for
us musicians and music lovers to use
amongst ourselves to communicate these
ideas you can also describe the
different sections of the piece in a
narrative way such as describing the
first section as having longing and
nostalgic gestures
then moving into a more nonchalant and
daydream-like excursion
and then here maybe a quiet prayer with
a sense of purpose
[Music]
and then an emotional build up here
where there's tension building while
maybe searching for answers
or maybe describing music in other
illustrative ways such as using colors
textures or shapes suits you much better
so as you can see analyzing a piece of
music can mean so many different things
and what i mentioned so far in the video
are things that i think can help you out
especially if you're a player or
performer because with all these
different bits and pieces of information
it'll help you form your own
interpretation of a certain piece
how you'll deal with the dynamics
phrasing pacing articulation all of that
and also speaking of performing
having these different points of clarity
and having a variety of them i think
really helps solidify your memorization
on stage or away from stage because
memorization is tricky i think it's
hard because it's such an abstract
concept and it's really hard to be
comfortable with the idea or
it's hard to feel secure about
remembering something especially
something with so many different details
and that's something that i personally
have always struggled with so i always
try to find different ways many
different ways of
analyzing a piece or just becoming
familiar with a piece in order to feel
more comfortable about memorization
how about we go for a walk
all right i'm gonna sit down so if
you're like me and you like composing
and improvising analyzing pieces in
these ways can give you new musical
ideas for example after analyzing this
particular musica i was inspired to
write a piece which i'll edit so that
you'll hear it in the background
and what's interesting is that lately
i've been writing a lot of music that is
highly repetitive pretty jagged
minimalistic and
fast-paced but with this piece i was in
a different headspace and it allowed me
to just have a change of pace literally
and i really loved it because
perhaps i it allowed me to express
something that was rather dormant as of
late
in terms of my
music writing language and i had a lot
of fun with it
one of the main ways i think of the
mazurka is in this
very narrative and descriptive way
using i don't know maybe a story made up
in my head so
in similar fashion when writing this
particular piece
which is not a mazurka it's
it has berserker-like qualities but it's
certainly not a mazurka and i wasn't
following any kind of form that chopin
was using
but when writing this i was also
thinking of a sort of storyline
that was drifting in and out of
my head when i was writing the piece so
i think there's something to be said
about that and
when we're inspired to create something
new
i think that's always a beautiful thing
[Music]
hello
hello
hi
another thing i want to add is that of
course everyone has
different ways of approaching music
different ways of understanding music
listening to music studying music
and everyone has a different personality
for me these things really help me
create really help me as a player and as
a listener but i understand it's not for
everyone and i think it can be a
distraction if you are stuck with those
details and you never end up
leaving some of those analytical details
behind and
giving the piece the breathing room that
it needs one thing is certain though i
do think that there's value in
considering all of these different
options and not shy away from
being too analytical because sometimes
there's a stigma against that and it
reminds me of this particular quote by i
think evie white i could be wrong okay i
just looked it up it is by eb white it
says explaining a joke is like
dissecting a frog you understand it
better but the frog dies in the process
and i think a lot of people think that
analyzing music is similar to this
because
you know you're overthinking it or
you're over examining it and you
take away from something sacred about it
but
i disagree i think
analyzing music
there are many different ways and that
being said it's just about paying
attention to music
in different ways different ways that
you prefer some are more technical than
others and
i think we shouldn't overthink
about overthinking things but anyway
these are just some of my thoughts
around
analyzing music
i'm all for it i think it's wonderful
and that is all by the way i have a
patreon if you don't already know i
upload additional content there in
between the videos that you see on
youtube and if you're already supporting
me there thank you so much
i have already uploaded a formal and
harmonic analysis of the berserker that
i talked about in the video as well as
the score and recording of the little
waltz i wrote that is all i appreciate
you all thank you so much and i'll see
you in the next
video so i asked the same question on my
instagram and here are some responses
building on my intuitions by informing
them
it's a great answer
to grow your musical vocabulary
to understand why it moves you thank you
amy
to train your ears based on the analysis
try to understand concepts
cuckoo
to improve one's understanding of music
and build a stronger musical vocabulary
yes ben levin
it helps me connect my emotional
response to music with the notes on the
page
erico
to understand how it's built how it
works how it was created
antonio perhaps analyzing music helps to
achieve a deeper appreciation and
experience
also what is the point of analyzing
anything in life
i like this one to enjoy less obvious
parts of music and to dive into the
composer's minds to get inspired with
more creative and innovative ideas to
enhance our music playing
for sure
to unlock the mystery
to find their fingerprints in the music
new techniques ideas etc
to be able to copy it and yet make
something new
difficult but a short answer would be
imitate internalize and innovate
to delay practicing
kim yes
to add different perspectives and draw
out alternative meanings and messages
than intended
to help you better articulate why you
like it
i like that as well
to learn the rules so you can break them
yes
thanks again see you next time